- Okay, Brie. I have
to ask you about this,
because from this moment from your show,
The Real Dirty Dancing, let's, well,
let's watch first.
- [Brie] Uh-oh.
♪ I want to show you
what love's all about ♪
♪ Darling tonight ♪
♪ Now, I've got you in my sights ♪
- [Kelly] Get it.
You gotta get it.
Here's my face.
- [Kelly] Wait, wait.
- So how does?
Do you tell your husband like,
Hey, well there's a show.
Do you watch it with him?
Like how does this play out?
Because I've been married.
- [Brie] Yeah.
- I don't know if that would've
gone over well.
- Well I think I do lie
to him when it airs.
I'm like, did you catch it last night?
And he's like, was it on I'm
like, oh yeah, it's tonight.
Oops. But I, you know,
he's actually great.
And I think it's cause
he's in entertainment.
He's also a professional
wrestler and gets it.
[Kelly] Yeah.
So he's really supportive.
He definitely has hard times.
Like I think Antonio
Gates is gonna get a yes
lock or choke cold put on him.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] I love that though.
He's secure.
So he is, he's fine.
- [Brie] Yeah, he is. He's really good.
- You are such a great dancer.
- Well, it was hard.
It was hard to bring up that
dirty side cause like really
- [Kelly] Really?
- You know, I mean
yeah, me too. (laughing)
- Yeah Kelly.
- You know, and it was the eye contact
like when you're moving
your hips with someone
and they're like, okay,
you have to sure of that.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Really?
- I love it too.
- Definitely.
- [Brie] See that was like
the uncomfortable part for me
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
I think I go into like,
I go into like, even
like when you like went clubbing
like when you were younger,
you didn't like, just like for fun
like you're just like
you go into character.
- [Brie] Yeah, I would.
But I was single then
- Or role play.
- Like I would do that.
I think it was more because I'm married
and I don't know if it's
being a mom for so long
you give your body to your kids.
So then all of a sudden I'm
have to give it to a stranger.
Someone I don't know.
And that was like the part
I had to like, the wall
I had to break down.
- [Kelly] I can see that.
- Right.
- Yeah. I don't know if it's weird but
I wouldn't have a problem with that.
- [Brie] Oh my gosh.
- Just fine then
- [Kelly] It's so great.
I love that though.
Dancing is so fun.
- It is.
- My friends will make
fun of me on group texts
cause they're like, what
are you gonna do tonight?
I'm like, I'm gonna go home
and dance. Just by myself.
Just put some music on.
Just have a good time.
- Well now you can call
me. I'll come over.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- Dirty dance with you.
- I will stare directly in your eyes mam.
- I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.